Philadelphia's Progressive D.A Larry
krasner trying to fend off an effort
from Republican lawmakers in his state
to impeach him over the city's exploding
crime rate for example since krasner
took office in 2017 murders have jumped
78 percent and the latest lunacy from
his office saw a convicted killer who he
exonerated and let out of prison last
year now wanted in connection with
another murder the krasner says
attacking his policies is just part of
the Republican Playbook
straight up this is an effort to impeach
someone for political purposes who has
done nothing corrupt and nothing illegal
because they want to erase
Philadelphia's votes part of the
Republican Playbook as you well know is
to point a finger at large diverse
cities
and say large diverse cities are Lawless
what we see here is the same old
Playbook
which is about coded and racist
messaging it's about blaming
the biggest city in Pennsylvania with
the most diverse population for having
the same National struggle that we have
with gun violence everywhere
that comes after President Biden offers
up his most confusing comment yet on
Rising crime
ahead of these midterms how big of an
issue is crime
I think it's a real issue and I think we
have a great record on it so Jesse it
seems like krasner is more upset with
quote the Republican Playbook than he is
about a convicted murderer who he
exonerated coming back and murdering
someone else he thinks he's a movie star
so the state legislature asked him to
come in and testify behind closed doors
about his crime policies and he turned
him down and then he flew from Philly to
Harrisburg and went to the Capitol steps
and held a press conference and called
the Republicans racist and said they
were pursuing a southern strategy so
Republicans are upset because a white
Democrat D.A is letting black people
kill each other and that's racist that's
Larry krasner's Theory right there Larry
krasner let out a guy who ran over a
woman and her baby daughter killing them
let him out on bail and then he went up
and shot up a high school football
practice Larry krasner has guy that was
in prison for murder and he had an
Integrity unit let him out and now he's
being charged with another murder and
he's wanted and he's on the lamb Larry
krasner is the worst D.A in this country
and he deserves everything that's coming
to him so judge you know this isn't just
about Republicans it's about real people
who are being victims of crimes and
women are being raped on public
transportation Lawrence Jones actually
sat down with a number of Voters to talk
to them about crime and safety we'll
listen to that and get your take
how many women out here feel like it's
safe for them to just even to pump your
gas here
No Hands who feels is unsafe
yeah and it's not just the women there
the fund the police message hurt the
city of Philadelphia and crime all over
uh the country uh raise your hand if you
believe the defund the police message
hurt us
yeah Lawrence also said all of those
people plan on voting for Republicans
judge okay first of all Larry krasner is
inept
he is a liar
he should not be D.A he should be the
public defender Larry krasner to stand
up there and say that this is about
erasing votes it has nothing to do with
that the one of the crimes that Jesse
talked about one of the murders that
Larry krasner's uh what is it his his uh
um I think it's it's conviction
Integrity unit decided to release
someone who had been convicted after a
jury trial and then he goes out and
kills again the first murder Jesse was
when this guy goes out and he kills a
man a father in front of his
five-year-old son point blank in front
of his son two days before Christmas and
krasner's conviction Integrity unit
decides that this is a man who deserves
mercy and this is a unit that is
supported by fetterman look the
Democrats own this crime crisis in the
United States they own it people like
krasner should be gone George gascon
Alvin Bragg Darcel Clark all of these
Progressive DA's do not belong in those
jobs and every woman I know now is
afraid to wear jewelry she's afraid to
drive a good car she's afraid she's
going to be followed home and they are
legitimately good reasons to be afraid
and it's because Democrats have decided
the cashless fail is the way to go for
social justice which no one is to find I
still don't know what social justice is
Harold
obviously people are being killed which
is the worst of it but this is also has
a negative economic impact I mean stores
are closing in places like Philadelphia
Washington DC because it's too dangerous
and of course the communities who live
there have less economic opportunity to
better their communities
right so I I am as concerned as any
about just a human toll and the kind of
the threats that people may feel about
their safety I don't view this as a
Democrat or Republican problem I view it
as a national challenge we have some
poor thinking and ineffective
individuals who happen to be Democrat in
some of these jobs this D.A he's right
in one regard you can't I don't know if
you can impeach him uh if he didn't do
anything corrupt but they should
certainly do everything they possibly
can to get him out of office Jesse I
thought you said it very well and
sometimes I think you try to be a little
political and Coy but you were you were
absolutely right when you said he just
went to Harrisburg I didn't think about
this way and said that they were racist
because they wanted him to prosecute
criminals who were in who were imparting
harm uh in fear on the parts of a
majority of the diverse population that
he talked about he shouldn't be D.A not
because he's not a probably a decent guy
who wants to do well but his his
policies are not working these DA's who
are who have who are still employing and
pursuing this platform of wanting to
release people from jail who commit
violent murderous acts I don't know what
we're accomplishing that seems to me
there's no social or Justice in any of
that the communities that they're
bringing us harm to ask those
communities if they feel as if this is
an act of social justice it's not where
you are right judge about us owning this
if we don't have a national message that
denounces Cash's Bell for violent
offenders if we don't make clear every
time the president speaks of the next
two weeks he must say we fully funded
the police we passed the policing bill
in the house and not one Republican
voted for it that's what he means when
he said he thought they were doing
better on it but whatever the case we
can't be for cashless bail Democrats if
we want safer communities and especially
if you want safe communities where
people like me and people who look like
me live
Jimmy
um listen man I think a kid solves this
when you were a little kid we used to
play a game in the backyard called cops
and robbers remember cops and robbers
and his kids
[Laughter]
I'm jealous of the robber because he's a
fat kid I could never get away like I
never I just never even bothered I'd
always got to drag that and just close
the gap but as kids you always knew the
cops are the good guys the robbers of
the bad guys we have created a system in
this country that has more empathy for
the criminal than the cop and this is
the residual effect of all of this what
I'm so blown away by is this narrative
being pushed on the left that
Republicans are evil for highlighting
all this crime we're the ones trying to
bring attention to it so we can stop it
they're the 911 operators that are
letting the call go to voicemail while
they play Candy Crush on their phone
there's no world where the people
sticking up for the cops are the bad
guys and if we just accept that I think
we have a foundation for a step forward
yeah all right well it's definitely an
issue hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else